and so today I had the honour of
cheering on behalf of a stand presidency
for their father for the last time on
this occasion the General Affairs
Council
we are the busy agenda this morning we
concluded the preparations for the
European Council meeting that will take
place on the 14th of December on the
agenda for the leaders there are two
main issues
security and defence and social issues
Education and Culture the heads will
also discuss migration on the leaders
agenda Council today also adopted
without discussion the mandate to start
negotiations with the European
Parliament on the European defense
industrial development programme edid P
this will support innovation and
increase the viability of the European
defence industry the council also
revealed the progress in other fields of
security and defence such as the EU NATO
cooperation the council proved today the
joint declaration of the EU institutions
on the common priorities until next
European Parliament elections in 2019 it
is a second such declaration and it has
already proved to be a valuable tool for
maintaining political attention of the
three institutions on main priorities of
EU the new joint declaration puts a
specific focus on economic growth
migration security and the well-being of
our citizens today we adopted without
discussion the action plan on
implementing the council conclusions on
cybersecurity strategy a high high level
of cyber cyber resilience across the U
is important for achieving trust in the
digital single market and further
development of a digital Europe